I alluded to this yesterday on the
members-only bonus show that there's
growing concern among Donald Trump
staffers about how they can avoid
confusing him and the extent to which
Donald Trump is confusable is a growing
area of concern for the people that are
working around him on a daily basis one
such example is that Donald Trump's
aides were looking for Twitter to put in
place a 15-minute delay on Donald
Trump's tweets such that they could
maybe be canceled or fixed or modified
before they go out I'll get to that in a
moment but there's a really interesting
storyline that's growing from reporting
by Politico and others about how Donald
Trump is being kept away from certain
people simply to avoid confusing him and
it's like dealing with a 9 year old kid
and in fact I would argue it's actually
like dealing with a cognitively limited
nine-year-old kid here's an example
shortly after ukrainian president
zolensky was elected an actual ukraine
expert the whistleblower that we now
know as Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN
Minh who's at the center of a lot of
controversy right now VIN Minh was set
to brief Donald Trump about zolensky why
well it made sense VIN Minh is an actual
Ukraine expert Trump needs to know
what's going on in Ukraine it makes
sense to have an expert brief Trump
about that issue
Trump staffers at the last second told
VIN Minh you know what don't show up
Trump will become confused by your
presence because Donald Trump is under
the impression that this other guy Kasia
Patel is actually the expert on Ukraine
now what's hilarious is that Kasia Patel
is not an expert on Ukraine Patel was a
Devin Nunez staffer Devan newness of
course the completely bogus and and
disgusting and depraved Republican
Congressmen Kasia
Patel has no expertise on Ukraine he has
no knowledge on Ukraine but Donald Trump
believed that cash yep Patel was the
expert on Ukraine and staffer said you
know if vind Minh shows up to talk to
Trump about Ukraine Trump will become
confused so they tell VIN Minh don't
show up even though VIN Minh is actually
the Ukraine expert this is tragic this
is sad but it's also disturbing when it
comes to in order to avoid confusing
Trump
people who aren't actually our real
experts on subject matter are being
chosen to brief Trump and the real
subject matter experts are being kept
out of the entire thing here's another
example it's the Twitter thing which I
mentioned Donald Trump's aides at one
point we're considering asking Twitter
to effectively reprogram the way that
the platform works just for Donald
Trump's account - in state a fifteen
minute delay on Donald Trump's tweets
this was earlier in Trump's presidency
and they wanted to do it without Trump's
knowledge and what was going on is that
Donald Trump's tweeting was obviously so
problematic from day one and staffers
were struggling with how to manage it
Trump was obviously not going to allow
someone the power to okay or not okay
his tweets so the idea was let's
secretly go to Twitter and let's have
them put a fifteen minute delay on
Donald Trump's tweets and during those
15 minutes
staffers presumably would be able to
either edit tweets delete them talk
Trump out of them whatever the case may
be understand the scope of this where
Trump is so erratic in his behavior but
also react so negatively to any attempt
at controlling or modifying his behavior
that staff were looking at asking one of
the largest social media platforms in
the world to program in functionality
just for Donald Trump's account
specifically to avoid the embarrassment
and problems that Donald Trump's
tweeting was causing never mind by the
way how potentially abused the tool
could be imagine if you are one of Trump
staffers and you see that Donald Trump
writes a tweet and you've got 15 minutes
to act on that tweet and you know that
it's a tweet that could for example tank
the stock price of a publicly traded
company during those 15 minutes you
could go and short that stock to make a
financial gain windfall really from what
you now can predict pretty safely
because Donald Trump's tweets move the
markets will be an upcoming shift in a
share price it's dangerous it's stunning
that this is something that it would
they would even consider asking a
platform like Twitter to do
and the reality is something that we've
known for a long time the people around
Donald Trump have to treat the guy like
as I said a poorly behaved or even
cognitively limited kid despite the fact
that he is you know a wealthy 73 year
old white guy born with a silver spoon
in his mouth who has not ever known any
actual adversity in his entire life and
yet still believes that he is the
greatest victim of the unfairness of the
world as he constantly talks about witch
hunts and presidential harassment and
how unfairly he's treated by the media
it is like dealing with a kid that is
what staffers are increasingly
describing sad but dangerous as well